imagine as a child you thought if you
could just get enough healing balloons
could you float away
and we're normally told no that's not
possible you're not going to be able to
fly with healing balloons but i
revisited that idea as an adult and i
argued if one balloon provides some unit
of lift why wouldn't we be able to scale
that
and that's what we're doing
[Music]
i'm flying my chair
[Music]
my name is trapp and i am a technical
projects manager at a large it
consulting forum as a day job but i have
a unusual passion hobby
which is to take helium balloons toy
helium balloons and assemble them in
massive clusters for manned flight
these are balloons that were never
intended to support manned flight but
that's what we've caused them to do 17
100 still climbing
that passion has carried me aloft on
more than a dozen flights across as many
years
sometimes it's just me just my body in a
tiny little harness sometimes we're
flying bigger things i've flown houses
what a thing to say i've flown houses
two of them
we were flying these toy helium balloons
before the disney pixar film up but i
will say this that the film up also
inspired us now the idea of flying a
house under toy helium balloons
absolutely came from the disney pixar
film
one of the things i love about flying
these helium balloons is they have the
capability for real expedition level
flights what i'm talking about is
flights of 23 000 feet in an open
gondola carried only by helium balloons
13 000 feet as we cross the alps it
varies from a small cluster couple dozen
balloons to extraordinarily large
towering clusters 365 of these massive
balloons we've flown clusters for 10
hours 12 hours uh you know 14 hours the
longest we've ever flown in a single
flight
466 miles
when i take off i don't know where i'm
going to put down i'll select a safe
place to land in flight but i'm flying
hundreds of miles without knowing
exactly where i'll land
[Music]
we're good
we're down
so it's a mix of art and science the art
is the colorful cluster of healing
balloons but the science is it is quite
serious and i treat it seriously there's
human life at stake my life and the
lives of those i share the sky with and
the lives of those under me hello
how are you
we work with the federal aviation
administration in terms of getting the
aircraft certified london this is gas
balloon calling to activate my flight
plan it took me about a year to go to
flight school get a pilot's license and
after about a year of tests and training
and certifications
we made our first flight using my
standard office chair as my gondola for
that flight
when you're up there it's not just
leisure and relaxation you're floating
away you have moments of that but
there's a lot more time spent thinking
okay am i heading the right direction do
i have any airspace or obstacles in
front of me okay we're climbing 120
right at 18 000 feet so it's trying to
get this guy to a zero pressure
configuration you have to fly the
aircraft if i'm climbing and i need to
initiate a descent i need to vent helium
the balloons are biodegradable so we can
also cut the balloons away cut away
individual balloons
so there's a whole calculation and it
changes every flight depending on what
i'm flying
[Music]
the feeling of launching is unparalleled
it's not like anything else to fly an
aircraft that's completely silent makes
no sound we're approaching sunset it's
really beautiful out there
there's no rotor there's no prop there's
no jet there's no burner like a hot air
balloon there's no roar of wind like you
get in a glider it's completely silent
like listen
there's no sound
so what's the whole point of this why do
it it's to lead an interesting life that
is the most beautiful moon rise i've
seen in my entire life
it enriches my life to look back and
reflect on what we've accomplished
[Applause]
i have all of those moments as prized
memories
to keep me warm in my old age
[Music]
hey everybody my name is drew bibi and
i'm here in my terrible home studio that
i've made during quarantine and i wanted
to tell you about our new podcast called
great big story it's got more surprising
and delightful stories just like this
one so head over to apple podcast to
spotify wherever you get your favorite
podcasts and download great big story